our next guest won season three of the
voice and then went on to become a
grammy-nominated platinum selling artist
in 2018 she returned to the voice but
this time with the better coach team
kelly
she was on mine she was a mentor and her
new single
is called what the star see and it's out
now everybody welcome cassidy bob
[Applause]
you look beautiful i love your hair oh
thank you i just got it done
i knew i was going to be honest i was
going to say it looks different than the
last time i saw you on the voice
um but i'm sorry once again that i
wasn't a coach this season you're on and
you had to go with blake you did all
right
but i'm just i apologize um but you you
have a new album
and you're revealing the title for the
first time right now so what is it
yes it's called thrive and i'm so
honored to be
revealing that on your show um
yeah i'm i'm so proud of it during the
pandemic i did
a lot of reflecting like everybody i'm
sure and um
and just kind of incorporating more of
my pop
punk roots into music now i've been
always singing country music as a kid
and um but pop punk has always been a
part of my journey as well so
i just kind of found this sweet spot of
incorporating all of it and finding that
blend
um so i hope that people get that from
the album i think that's brilliant
and to do one thing your entire career
can kind of get monotonous
um but the song you're doing today is
called what the stars see so what what's
it about
so um i actually wrote that that was my
first zoom session
which i was terrified to do because i've
never done a virtual writing session
ever
um but it was during the pandemic and i
was like i
guess i gotta jump on the bandwagon or
i'm never gonna write
for a year so i uh i was sitting
on our deck and it was a starry night
here in nashville and i just looked up
and was like man
the stars can really see um everything
and it just reminded me of all those
times i'd been through a breakup
or i had maybe you know lost a friend or
i don't know people just they're not in
your lives anymore you used to know
everything about them
and um all of a sudden you know nothing
so it just kind of popped into my head
um what the stars see
that that uh title so i'm really proud
of how it turned out
oh man it's that's amazing i love the
the idea is brilliant you know that the
stars see everything it's such a cool
idea
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure